This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.|||这是一个iHeart播客。真人保证。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，如何培养心理韧性、保持体能以及建立复原力。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.|||经历一些艰难困苦，你将会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。即数字 2。可在 iHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个惯犯骗手交往过时，她们决定采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.|||他会得到应有的惩罚。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。听闺蜜的话。相信我，宝贝。可在 iHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我来说是一个重要时刻。84年对我来说也很重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.|||我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利希。每一集里，我们会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何挺过来的。与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年真是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that. you need to listen to learn the hard way on the iha radio app apple podcast or wherever you get your podcast
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that. you need to listen to learn the hard way on the iha radio app apple podcast or wherever you get your podcast|||请在 iHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人 Kear Games 主持的《Learn the Hardway》。这个空间聚焦于黑人男性的经历，进行在其他任何地方都不太安全的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。这向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着...你需要在 iHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《Learn the Hardway》。
hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode. Welcome to the 12 Days of Guests this December. Today we have on such a fabulous guest. I'm so excited. And honestly, the origins of this friendship. The origins of this episode are kind of amazing. And I think we're very much. really sure like the power of the internet. Tiff Barra. You would know her from Strayha's NYC. Maybe you saw her on the Drew Baramore show. You see her on TikTok. She's the queen of confidence and we're obsessed with her. Welcome to Tith. Yeah, well, I'm so happy to be here. I know I've told you before, but I am your biggest fan. So I've been listening to this podcast for like the last year and it's helped me through some dark nights. So I'm so happy to be here. Wasn't it like the episode that I did on
hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode. Welcome to the 12 Days of Guests this December. Today we have on such a fabulous guest. I'm so excited. And honestly, the origins of this friendship. The origins of this episode are kind of amazing. And I think we're very much. really sure like the power of the internet. Tiff Barra. You would know her from Strayha's NYC. Maybe you saw her on the Drew Baramore show. You see her on TikTok. She's the queen of confidence and we're obsessed with her. Welcome to Tith. Yeah, well, I'm so happy to be here. I know I've told you before, but I am your biggest fan. So I've been listening to this podcast for like the last year and it's helped me through some dark nights. So I'm so happy to be here. Wasn't it like the episode that I did on|||大家好，欢迎回到《20多岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们探讨20多岁时的一些重大生活变化和转型，以及它们对我们心理的意义。大家好。欢迎回到本节目。欢迎回到本播客。新听友，老听友，无论你们身在世界的哪个角落。很高兴你们能回来收听另一期节目。欢迎来到今年12月的“12天嘉宾”系列。今天我们请到了一位非常棒的嘉宾。我太兴奋了。老实说，这段友谊的渊源。这一集的起源简直太神奇了。我想我们非常、真的很确信互联网的力量。蒂芙·巴拉（Tiff Barra）。你可能从 Strayha's NYC 认识她。也许你在德鲁·巴里摩尔秀上见过她。你在 TikTok 上也能看到她。她是自信女王，我们对她着迷不已。欢迎蒂芙。是的，我很高兴能来到这里。我知道我之前跟你说过，我是你的超级粉丝。所以我过去一年左右一直在听这个播客，它帮我度过了一些黑暗的夜晚。所以我很高兴能来到这里。难道不是我做的那期关于...
anxiety and you were like yeah i i still probably listen to that once a month there without one night where i have too many espresso martinis i always listened to that and i'm like it's okay like it's all gabba gamma oh my god you know it's all glutamate gather gather gabba that is so funny and you definitely have listened to that episode i need to listen to that episode probably a little bit more because i was like i went out the other night and then i like work up the next morning and i was like everyone hates me and I have no friends. And I'm sure you felt that. And can we talk about how like as you get in your later 20s, like I'm 26, but when I was 21,
anxiety and you were like yeah i i still probably listen to that once a month there without one night where i have too many espresso martinis i always listened to that and i'm like it's okay like it's all gabba gamma oh my god you know it's all glutamate gather gather gabba that is so funny and you definitely have listened to that episode i need to listen to that episode probably a little bit more because i was like i went out the other night and then i like work up the next morning and i was like everyone hates me and I have no friends. And I'm sure you felt that. And can we talk about how like as you get in your later 20s, like I'm 26, but when I was 21,|||焦虑的节目吗，然后你说“对，我大概每个月还是会听一次，每当我有一晚喝了太多浓缩咖啡马提尼时，我总是会听那个，然后我想‘没关系，这都是伽马氨基丁酸...天哪，你知道的，这都是谷氨酸，gather gather gabba（语无伦次）’”，这太搞笑了，你绝对听过那一集。我可能需要再多听听那一集，因为我想起前天晚上我出门了，然后第二天早上醒来，我心想“所有人都在讨厌我，我没有朋友”。我相信你也有过这种感觉。我们能聊聊随着你进入25岁后期——比如我26岁，但当我21岁的时候...
I never had anxiety. And like now I'm like, oh my, it'll last like five days. The last five days. You're like, honestly, it's this weird thing where I think it's like you have more to lose. You're not like just like, wow, crazy party girl, which is like kind of what I was at like 2021. Now you're like, oh, like what I say actually means something. I think it's like that frontal lobe developing and you're being.
I never had anxiety. And like now I'm like, oh my, it'll last like five days. The last five days. You're like, honestly, it's this weird thing where I think it's like you have more to lose. You're not like just like, wow, crazy party girl, which is like kind of what I was at like 2021. Now you're like, oh, like what I say actually means something. I think it's like that frontal lobe developing and you're being.|||我从来没有过焦虑。而现在我会觉得，天哪，这会持续大约五天。过去的五天。你会觉得，老实说，这是一件很奇怪的事情，我觉得就好像你现在有更多东西要失去了。你不再只是那种“哇，疯狂的派对女孩”，那大概是我20、21岁时的状态。现在你会想，哦，我所说的话实际上是有分量的。我想这就像是前额叶皮层发育了，然后你开始...
like my actions have consequences and so then you get like more intense feelings towards your anxiety but then also your body just can't take the drinks as well as it used to right it cannot take it as well you know like I did a whole but what's what's great is like as you get older the hope is that you have like really good friends around you so like when you do the apology tour the next day they're like Tiffany stop being ridiculous you were literally fine like I didn't even know you drank and I'm like okay that's what I need to hear yeah so it's like You learn to surround yourself by people that have your back just as much as we should have our own backs. That's actually such great advice.
like my actions have consequences and so then you get like more intense feelings towards your anxiety but then also your body just can't take the drinks as well as it used to right it cannot take it as well you know like I did a whole but what's what's great is like as you get older the hope is that you have like really good friends around you so like when you do the apology tour the next day they're like Tiffany stop being ridiculous you were literally fine like I didn't even know you drank and I'm like okay that's what I need to hear yeah so it's like You learn to surround yourself by people that have your back just as much as we should have our own backs. That's actually such great advice.|||意识到我的行为会产生后果，所以你对焦虑会有更强烈的感觉，但同时你的身体也无法像以前那样承受酒精了，对吧，它确实不如以前能喝了，你知道的，就像我做了一个...但棒就棒在，随着你年龄的增长，理想情况下你的身边会有真正的好朋友，所以当你在第二天进行“道歉之旅”时，他们会说：“蒂芬妮，别开玩笑了，你明明好得很，我都不知道你喝了酒”，然后我想“好吧，这正是我需要听到的”。是的，所以这就好像...你学会了让那些支持你的人环绕在身边，就像我们应该支持自己一样。这其实真是个绝佳的建议。
We've like jumped straight into it, but I feel like I haven't even given you. We're like, let's talk about it. I haven't even given you an opportunity to tell the audience a little bit about yourself. I know I gave you a bit of an introduction, but in your own words, who is Tiff? Yeah, well, I'm Tiff Barra. I'm in New York City, and I've really kind of been sharing my experience. of dating and being a dating coach for like the last three years on TikTok, which then led to me becoming an actual dating coach on a Roku show match me in Miami, where I've worked with
We've like jumped straight into it, but I feel like I haven't even given you. We're like, let's talk about it. I haven't even given you an opportunity to tell the audience a little bit about yourself. I know I gave you a bit of an introduction, but in your own words, who is Tiff? Yeah, well, I'm Tiff Barra. I'm in New York City, and I've really kind of been sharing my experience. of dating and being a dating coach for like the last three years on TikTok, which then led to me becoming an actual dating coach on a Roku show match me in Miami, where I've worked with|||我们好像直接切入正题了，但我觉得我甚至都还没给你...我们就像是在说，来聊聊这个吧。我甚至都还没给你一个机会向听众介绍一下你自己。我知道我刚才简单做了一点介绍，但用你自己的话说，蒂芙是谁？是的，嗯，我是蒂芙·巴拉。我在纽约市，过去三年左右，我其实一直在 TikTok 上分享我的约会经验，并担任约会教练，这后来促使我成为了 Roku 节目《在迈阿密匹配我》中的真正约会教练，在节目中我和...
hundreds of singles. I have a practice where I work with singles. And really the difference between what I do and what some of the previous matchmakers that you've seen on the scene are is that my major thing is finding love while loving yourself. Dema, I don't know about you, but like in my early 20s and even to now, it is a full struggle. bus trying to figure out how to navigate dating while not being harsh on yourself and not blaming yourself for your dating life, not always going the way you want it to. So really like the ethos of what I do is like how to enjoy being single, how to love yourself at the same time while putting yourself out there and realizing that like rejection may happen, but it's not a problem with you.
hundreds of singles. I have a practice where I work with singles. And really the difference between what I do and what some of the previous matchmakers that you've seen on the scene are is that my major thing is finding love while loving yourself. Dema, I don't know about you, but like in my early 20s and even to now, it is a full struggle. bus trying to figure out how to navigate dating while not being harsh on yourself and not blaming yourself for your dating life, not always going the way you want it to. So really like the ethos of what I do is like how to enjoy being single, how to love yourself at the same time while putting yourself out there and realizing that like rejection may happen, but it's not a problem with you.|||上百名单身人士合作过。我有一家专门为单身人士服务的诊所。实际上，我所做的和我所见过的现场其他红娘的区别在于，我的核心理念是在爱自己的同时寻找真爱。德玛，我不知道你怎么样，但在我20岁出头甚至直到现在，要想弄清楚如何在不苛求自己、不因为约会生活不如意而责备自己的情况下驾驭约会，简直是一场彻底的挣扎。所以，我所做事情的宗旨其实就是：如何享受单身生活，如何在勇敢走出去的同时学会爱自己，并意识到拒绝可能会发生，但这并不是你的问题。
It's a compatibility issue. So I help clients really just learn like number one, how do I learn to love myself before going out into the dating world? Because if you can't tell yourself like, what you deserve, build your standards, learn what actual love is for yourself. It's very hard to find it. And it also leads you to settling for the wrong people that may not treat you the way you deserve and calling that love. So we're in the business of building high standards, building high confidence and working through the vulnerabilities and insecurities that I think we all have specifically in our 20s. Honestly, that hits home for me because I think about people that I know who are like actively dating right now, I think about my like past self when she
It's a compatibility issue. So I help clients really just learn like number one, how do I learn to love myself before going out into the dating world? Because if you can't tell yourself like, what you deserve, build your standards, learn what actual love is for yourself. It's very hard to find it. And it also leads you to settling for the wrong people that may not treat you the way you deserve and calling that love. So we're in the business of building high standards, building high confidence and working through the vulnerabilities and insecurities that I think we all have specifically in our 20s. Honestly, that hits home for me because I think about people that I know who are like actively dating right now, I think about my like past self when she|||这是一个契合度的问题。因此，我帮助客户真正学会的第一件事是：在进入约会世界之前，我该如何学会爱自己？因为如果你无法告诉自己：你值得拥有什么，建立你的标准，了解对你而言真正的爱是什么。你就很难找到它。这也容易导致你将就那些不对的人，他们可能无法给予你应有的对待，而你却把这称为爱。所以我们的宗旨是建立高标准、建立高自信，并克服我认为我们在20岁时普遍存在的脆弱感和不安全感。老实说，这深深触动了我，因为我想到了我认识的那些目前正在积极约会的人，我想到了过去的那个自己...
was actively dating and how much I thought the way other people treated me or the decisions they made about our relationship reflected something deeper about myself. And now I realize like being in a really healthy relationship, I am so glad that those people rejected me because otherwise I wouldn't have rejected myself and I would have like continued to pursue them for. so long and I didn't like I deserve so much better but it's so interesting like how you don't realize that until you really start to like cultivate your own self-worth oh no I'm just to that it's like I really do believe that like rejection is redirection like the people that are rejecting you are leading you to where you need to be like all the noes are leading you to your yes and and like
was actively dating and how much I thought the way other people treated me or the decisions they made about our relationship reflected something deeper about myself. And now I realize like being in a really healthy relationship, I am so glad that those people rejected me because otherwise I wouldn't have rejected myself and I would have like continued to pursue them for. so long and I didn't like I deserve so much better but it's so interesting like how you don't realize that until you really start to like cultivate your own self-worth oh no I'm just to that it's like I really do believe that like rejection is redirection like the people that are rejecting you are leading you to where you need to be like all the noes are leading you to your yes and and like|||当时她正在积极约会，并且曾认为其他人对待我的方式或他们对我们关系的决定，反映了我身上的某种更深层次的东西。而现在我意识到，身处一段真正健康的感情中，我无比庆幸当初那些人拒绝了我，因为否则我就不会拒绝自己，而且我会花那么长时间继续追求他们...而我并不喜欢那样，我值得更好的。但非常有趣的是，直到你真正开始培养自己的自我价值感之前，你是不会意识到这一点的。哦，不，我完全赞同这一点，就好像我真的坚信——拒绝就是重定向，那些拒绝你的人正在引导你走向你需要去的地方，所有的“不”都在引导你走向你的“是”，并且...
I think what you were saying it hit me too because it's like a lot of times we like to reaffirm the stories we tell ourselves. So if we say we don't deserve love, you're going to constantly date people that make you feel unlove because you're already telling yourself that's what you deserve. So it's very uncomfortable to step out of that cycle of toxic guys or people that don't give you enough because then you're saying like, hey, I deserve more, but it's going to be uncomfortable to get there because you're kind of walking away from all you've known. And also you're walking away from what feels really exciting. Like the chase feels exciting. Having someone who is like never giving you 100% feels exciting because you're like how do I get that 100% like I'm going to fucking work for it
I think what you were saying it hit me too because it's like a lot of times we like to reaffirm the stories we tell ourselves. So if we say we don't deserve love, you're going to constantly date people that make you feel unlove because you're already telling yourself that's what you deserve. So it's very uncomfortable to step out of that cycle of toxic guys or people that don't give you enough because then you're saying like, hey, I deserve more, but it's going to be uncomfortable to get there because you're kind of walking away from all you've known. And also you're walking away from what feels really exciting. Like the chase feels exciting. Having someone who is like never giving you 100% feels exciting because you're like how do I get that 100% like I'm going to fucking work for it|||我觉得你刚才说的话也触动了我，因为很多时候我们喜欢不断印证我们对自己讲述的故事。所以如果我们说自己不配得到爱，你就会不断和那些让你觉得自己不被爱的人约会，因为你已经在心里告诉自己，这才是你应得的。因此，要跳出那种充满毒性的人或无法给予你足够关爱的人的循环是非常不舒服的，因为这意味着你在说：“嘿，我值得拥有更多”，但要达到那个状态会很不舒服，因为你有点像是在背离你所熟悉的一切。同时，你也在背离那些感觉非常刺激的东西。比如追逐的过程感觉很刺激。身边有一个从不给你100%投入的人感觉很刺激，因为你会想：我该如何得到那100%的爱呢？我他妈的要为此努力。
there's something about me that I can change and once I figure it out everything's going to be perfect but it's so interesting because it's like it's like what the fuck like sometimes I think back to you know that experience to myself and I'm like how like when you're in it you don't realize that like that excitement that you feel is really just anxiety and it's really just your body and your brain being like, you should know right now that you deserve better. And we're trying really hard to tell you that. Oh my God. It's so true. I think like what you're saying is so spot on where it's like back when I was first experimenting with dating when my self-esteem was pretty low, I didn't meet people at the beginning who thought I had value. I thought like I had to prove my value. So now I'm always like,
there's something about me that I can change and once I figure it out everything's going to be perfect but it's so interesting because it's like it's like what the fuck like sometimes I think back to you know that experience to myself and I'm like how like when you're in it you don't realize that like that excitement that you feel is really just anxiety and it's really just your body and your brain being like, you should know right now that you deserve better. And we're trying really hard to tell you that. Oh my God. It's so true. I think like what you're saying is so spot on where it's like back when I was first experimenting with dating when my self-esteem was pretty low, I didn't meet people at the beginning who thought I had value. I thought like I had to prove my value. So now I'm always like,|||我身上一定有什么地方是可以改变的，一旦我弄清楚了，一切都会变得完美。但这非常有趣，因为有时候回想起自己当年的那种经历，我会想：身处其中时，你根本不会意识到，你感受到的那种兴奋感其实只是焦虑，其实只是你的身体和大脑在对你说：“你现在应该明白你值得更好的了。我们正在努力告诉你这一点。”天哪。太对了。我觉得你说的简直太准了：当我在最初尝试约会、自尊心还很低的时候，我一开始遇到的人并不觉得我有价值。我觉得自己必须证明自己的价值。所以现在我总是说：
you're not doing a PowerPoint presentation. Like your job is not to convince or to persuade. They should already meet you knowing your value you know nobody walks into like um nobody walks into chanelle and is like well i know it's listed at 2000 but like i'm just going to give a hundred dollars is that okay you know what i mean it's like you you are the cashier you're the one that's setting the price so don't set it for a hundred when you know the actual value and i think it's very you learn that with time i hope and also with realizing that like the guys that treat you like shit at the beginning are going to treat you even worse at the end. You cannot change treatment. You can only change who's in your life. You know, if it starts bad, typically, I mean, I can't say like 100%, but if someone's already not
you're not doing a PowerPoint presentation. Like your job is not to convince or to persuade. They should already meet you knowing your value you know nobody walks into like um nobody walks into chanelle and is like well i know it's listed at 2000 but like i'm just going to give a hundred dollars is that okay you know what i mean it's like you you are the cashier you're the one that's setting the price so don't set it for a hundred when you know the actual value and i think it's very you learn that with time i hope and also with realizing that like the guys that treat you like shit at the beginning are going to treat you even worse at the end. You cannot change treatment. You can only change who's in your life. You know, if it starts bad, typically, I mean, I can't say like 100%, but if someone's already not|||你又不是在做PPT演示。你的工作不是去说服或游说别人。他们遇见你时就应该已经知道你的价值了，你知道的，没有人会走进...呃，没有人走进香奈儿然后说：“嗯，我知道标价是2000，但我只想给100块钱，这样行吗？”你知道我的意思吗？这就好比你、你就是收银员，你才是那个定价的人，所以当你知道实际价值时，不要把它定在100块。我想随着时间推移，你会慢慢明白这一点，同时也会意识到：一开始就对你像对待垃圾一样不尊重的人，到最后只会对你更差。你无法改变别人的对待方式。你只能改变谁留在你的生命里。你知道的，如果一开始就很糟糕，通常情况下——我的意思是不能说百分之百——但如果某人一开始就已经...
treating you with respect or the right way, it 99% doesn't get better. You know what I mean? You want someone that at first sight is excited about you, someone that already is ready to meet you where you are and knows your value without you having to prove anything. Additionally, you know, 99% of those relationships end, but I saw this thing the other day that was like, would the love of your life really treat you that way? Is that really like the story you want to tell your kids? Like, oh, when your daddy and I first met,
treating you with respect or the right way, it 99% doesn't get better. You know what I mean? You want someone that at first sight is excited about you, someone that already is ready to meet you where you are and knows your value without you having to prove anything. Additionally, you know, 99% of those relationships end, but I saw this thing the other day that was like, would the love of your life really treat you that way? Is that really like the story you want to tell your kids? Like, oh, when your daddy and I first met,|||没有用尊重或正确的方式对待你，那有99%的可能都不会变好。你知道我的意思吗？你会希望找到这样一个人：他第一眼看到你就为你兴奋，他已经准备好在你的位置上理解你，并且无需你证明任何东西就知道你的价值。另外，你知道的，99%的这种关系最终都会以结束告终。但我前几天看到一句话，大意是：你生命中的真爱真的会那样对你吗？这真的是你想讲给孩子们听的故事吗？比如：“哦，当年你爸爸和我刚认识的时候...
like, he like ghosted me and ignored me. And like, I used to beg him for flowers and he'd never give them to me. Like, what a cute story, kids. Like, he had a roster of like three girlfriends. I didn't know. But like, he would text me sometimes at 4 a.m. And I thought it was romantic. Yeah.
like, he like ghosted me and ignored me. And like, I used to beg him for flowers and he'd never give them to me. Like, what a cute story, kids. Like, he had a roster of like three girlfriends. I didn't know. But like, he would text me sometimes at 4 a.m. And I thought it was romantic. Yeah.|||他突然人间蒸发然后无视我。而且，我以前求他送我花，但他从来不送。孩子们，多可爱的一个故事啊。比如，他脚踏几只船，同时有大约三个女朋友，而我当时并不知道。但有时候他会在凌晨4点给我发信息，我还以为那是浪漫。是的。
Or like, you know, he like told me that he was sleeping with other. people and I just was like, all right, he'll change his mind. And then he did and now I'm so happy. It's like, is that really how the love of your life would treat you? If they don't know, like, from the get go, I don't know. I don't think that they like suddenly become more aware. But you know, Jim, I think the biggest thing that allows us to make these red flags green is our fear of being alone. And I think that's one thing that I really try to encourage. It's something that I work with on myself. Like, it's better to be alone right now than with someone that makes you feel lonely. I think that's something that I learned the hard way. When I was younger, I was like doing really
Or like, you know, he like told me that he was sleeping with other. people and I just was like, all right, he'll change his mind. And then he did and now I'm so happy. It's like, is that really how the love of your life would treat you? If they don't know, like, from the get go, I don't know. I don't think that they like suddenly become more aware. But you know, Jim, I think the biggest thing that allows us to make these red flags green is our fear of being alone. And I think that's one thing that I really try to encourage. It's something that I work with on myself. Like, it's better to be alone right now than with someone that makes you feel lonely. I think that's something that I learned the hard way. When I was younger, I was like doing really|||或者像，你知道的，他告诉我他在和别人上床，而我当时心想：好吧，他会改变主意的。然后他真的改变了，现在我太幸福了。这就像是，生命中的真爱真的会这样对待你吗？如果他们从一开始就不懂得...我不知道。我不认为他们会突然变得更有意识。但你知道吗，吉姆，我认为让我们把这些红灯（危险信号）当成绿灯（安全信号）的最大原因，是我们对孤独的恐惧。我觉得这也是我一直在努力鼓励大家的事情。这也是我一直在自己身上努力克服的事情。比如，现在一个人呆着，也比和一个让你感到孤独的人在一起要好。我想这是我通过沉重代价学到的教训。当我年轻的时候，我一直在做一些...
casual hookups with guys that didn't deserve me or just going, filling my time to not feel alone. But what you're actually doing in the long run is going to make you more alone longer. Because you're not creating space for the right people. You're like basically putting bad boy band-aids across your journey and you're not leaving space for some of that actually deserves you. So the biggest thing that I've done and have really focused on, if it's not 100% what I want or what I deserve, I'm not going to just be like, oh, well, it's Saturday night. I have nothing to do. Let me go get a free dinner with a cute guy because I already know that that's not, that's wasting my time of what my goals are. Now, there's so many different goals. Like,
casual hookups with guys that didn't deserve me or just going, filling my time to not feel alone. But what you're actually doing in the long run is going to make you more alone longer. Because you're not creating space for the right people. You're like basically putting bad boy band-aids across your journey and you're not leaving space for some of that actually deserves you. So the biggest thing that I've done and have really focused on, if it's not 100% what I want or what I deserve, I'm not going to just be like, oh, well, it's Saturday night. I have nothing to do. Let me go get a free dinner with a cute guy because I already know that that's not, that's wasting my time of what my goals are. Now, there's so many different goals. Like,|||随意的露水情缘，和那些根本配不上我的男生鬼混，或者只是到处闲逛，用填满时间来逃避孤独。但从长远来看，你实际上在做的事情只会让你孤独更久。因为你没有为对的人腾出空间。你基本上就像是在自己的旅程中贴满了坏男孩创可贴，而没有给那些真正配得上你的人留出空间。所以我做过最重要的事情、也是我真正专注于的事情是：如果不是100%符合我的心意或我应得的，我不会仅仅因为“哦，好吧，今天是周六晚上，我没事可做，让我去找一个帅哥蹭顿免费晚饭吧”而去做，因为我心里很清楚，那不是...那是在浪费我实现目标的宝贵时间。当然，人生有各种各样的目标。比如...
if that's what you want, absolutely go out and do it. Like, I think the biggest thing, we all own our own dating stories and you know monogamy is not for everybody if you want to date a million people go ahead do things that make you feel good but make sure that you're doing it to add to your confidence to add to what you really want and not just something to distract you from the fear of being alone because I hope that everyone starts to learn that being alone is a beautiful thing like being alone with yourself is the best company like what oh my god solitude is sacred I always say that on this show and I love that I know solitude is so sacred and not only that like either relationship be happy with yourself is the most important one.
if that's what you want, absolutely go out and do it. Like, I think the biggest thing, we all own our own dating stories and you know monogamy is not for everybody if you want to date a million people go ahead do things that make you feel good but make sure that you're doing it to add to your confidence to add to what you really want and not just something to distract you from the fear of being alone because I hope that everyone starts to learn that being alone is a beautiful thing like being alone with yourself is the best company like what oh my god solitude is sacred I always say that on this show and I love that I know solitude is so sacred and not only that like either relationship be happy with yourself is the most important one.|||如果那就是你想要的，完全可以走出去去做。就像，我认为最重要的一点是，我们每个人都拥有自己的约会故事，而且你知道一夫一妻制并不适合所有人，如果你想和一百万人约会，那就去吧，去做那些让你感觉良好的事情，但要确保你这么做是为了增加你的自信，为了增进你真正想要的东西，而不仅仅是为了转移你对孤独的恐惧。因为我希望每个人都开始明白，独处是一件美好的事，比如与自己独处是最好的陪伴，就像什么...天哪，独处是神圣的！我总是在这个节目里这么说，我太喜欢这句话了。我知道独处是如此神圣，不仅如此，无论是哪种关系，对自己感到满意才是最重要的一段关系。
It's the only one that lasts your whole life. So it's so interesting that we don't take time to really cultivate it. You said something though that I think that I really want to talk about today. If you are familiar with TIFF's content, the thing that I love about you is how unapologetically yourself you are. It's like this aura of confidence that I think a lot of people are like, like I freaking want that like I want to knock him what other people have to say you just like imbue the sense like it's just this charm it's like so refreshing have you always been like that have you
It's the only one that lasts your whole life. So it's so interesting that we don't take time to really cultivate it. You said something though that I think that I really want to talk about today. If you are familiar with TIFF's content, the thing that I love about you is how unapologetically yourself you are. It's like this aura of confidence that I think a lot of people are like, like I freaking want that like I want to knock him what other people have to say you just like imbue the sense like it's just this charm it's like so refreshing have you always been like that have you|||它是唯一一段能伴随你一生的关系。所以很有趣的是，我们居然没有花时间去真正培养它。不过你刚才说了一句话，我觉得那是我今天非常想聊的话题。如果你熟悉蒂芙的内容，我最喜欢你的一点就是你毫不在意别人眼光、尽情做自己的态度。那种自信的气场，让很多人都觉得：“天哪，我太想要那种状态了，我想知道别人怎么看他”，你身上自然而然地散发着这种感觉，就像是一种迷人的魅力，让人耳目一新。你一直都是这样的吗？你...
always been this like confident bubbly person absolutely not um I think the biggest thing when I was growing up I was bullied really badly like probably since I can remember I remember like since kindergarten being called the fat girl. And it was always very isolating. And then I was like, okay, well, what's my social capital going to be? Let me just be funny. You're like, really, I had to build. It's just really crazy thing. When you get bullied when you're young, you start strategizing how to not get bullied. And for me, that was like, well, if I'm funny, if I talk to everybody, I can kind of fit in, right? But for my whole life until about 20, 18 to 20, it was about fitting it. I wanted to fit in. I was trying to squeeze into this smaller version of myself.
always been this like confident bubbly person absolutely not um I think the biggest thing when I was growing up I was bullied really badly like probably since I can remember I remember like since kindergarten being called the fat girl. And it was always very isolating. And then I was like, okay, well, what's my social capital going to be? Let me just be funny. You're like, really, I had to build. It's just really crazy thing. When you get bullied when you're young, you start strategizing how to not get bullied. And for me, that was like, well, if I'm funny, if I talk to everybody, I can kind of fit in, right? But for my whole life until about 20, 18 to 20, it was about fitting it. I wanted to fit in. I was trying to squeeze into this smaller version of myself.|||一直都是这样一个自信、开朗的人吗？绝对不是。嗯，我觉得最主要的是，在我成长过程中，我遭受了非常严重的欺凌。大概从我有记忆起就开始了，我记得从幼儿园起就被叫“胖女孩”。那种感觉总是非常孤立无援。然后我想：好吧，那我该有什么社交资本呢？让我变得搞笑一点吧。你就好像在说：真的，我不得不去建立。这真是一件疯狂的事情。当你年轻时遭受欺凌，你就会开始筹划如何不再被欺凌。对我来说，那就是：如果我很幽默，如果我和每个人都说话，我就能勉强融入进去，对吧？但在我大约18到20岁之前的整个人生中，一切都是为了“融入”。我想要融入集体。我一直在试图把自己塞进一个更小、更局促的自我之中。
And it was very uncomfortable because I started, I kind of got to the point where it was like, I'm never going to be anybody else's idea of me. I'm never going to be good enough for other people's standards. So I have to create my own standard. And it was this very freeing moment where I was like, okay, like, okay, so the biggest thing that now of like all my wheels are turning. What really set me free when it came to my confidence was relativity, was understanding that there's not one way to be. that there's not one opinion that sets your worth. Like, you could have 10 guys in a room and one of them will think you're hot.
And it was very uncomfortable because I started, I kind of got to the point where it was like, I'm never going to be anybody else's idea of me. I'm never going to be good enough for other people's standards. So I have to create my own standard. And it was this very freeing moment where I was like, okay, like, okay, so the biggest thing that now of like all my wheels are turning. What really set me free when it came to my confidence was relativity, was understanding that there's not one way to be. that there's not one opinion that sets your worth. Like, you could have 10 guys in a room and one of them will think you're hot.|||那感觉非常难受，因为我开始……我差不多到了这样一个地步：我永远不会成为别人心目中的我。我永远无法达到别人眼中的好标准。所以我必须建立我自己的标准。那是一个非常解放的时刻，我想：好吧，好吧，现在我脑海里的齿轮全都在飞速运转。真正让我在自信方面获得解放的是“相对性”，是理解了人生并非只有一种活法，没有哪一种观点能够决定你的价值。比如，一个房间里可能有10个男人，其中一个会觉得你很辣。
One of them will think you're ugly. One of them thinks you look like a stover's lasagna. One of them thinks you're like a honey baked ham. One of you thinks you're Miss America. Right. So once you understand that, you're like, why the fuck am I? Can I curse on here? Yeah, you can.
One of them will think you're ugly. One of them thinks you look like a stover's lasagna. One of them thinks you're like a honey baked ham. One of you thinks you're Miss America. Right. So once you understand that, you're like, why the fuck am I? Can I curse on here? Yeah, you can.|||其中一个会觉得你很丑。其中一个觉得你长得像斯托弗千层面。其中一个觉得你像蜜汁烤火腿。其中一个觉得你是美国小姐。对吧。所以一旦你明白了这一点，你就会想：我他妈的为什么...我能在这里说脏话吗？可以，没问题。
Oh, okay. I'm like, I'm like, why am I chasing all these other people's standards? Because then you're just wasting your fumes. You're wasting your energy chasing all these things. And then you don't know what you really want. So finally, after just being like, okay, well, I don't fit into this bubble. I don't fit into that bubble. I'm never going to be this.
Oh, okay. I'm like, I'm like, why am I chasing all these other people's standards? Because then you're just wasting your fumes. You're wasting your energy chasing all these things. And then you don't know what you really want. So finally, after just being like, okay, well, I don't fit into this bubble. I don't fit into that bubble. I'm never going to be this.|||哦，好的。我心想，我心想：我为什么要去追逐所有这些别人的标准？因为那样你只是在浪费燃料。你在把精力浪费在追逐所有这些事情上。到头来你根本不知道自己真正想要什么。所以最终，在经历了一番“好吧，我既不适合这个泡泡，也不适合那个泡泡，我永远不会成为这样，我也永远不会成为那样”的想法之后，我决定停下来。我究竟想要成为什么样的人？
I'm never going to be that. Let me stop. Like, what do I want to be? And from there, I've started this journey of just really exploring what I want. And I think the key thing, the key to confidence is exploring at first. Confidence is not something that just happens overnight. And it's not something that lasts forever. You have to constantly be cultivating your confidence.
I'm never going to be that. Let me stop. Like, what do I want to be? And from there, I've started this journey of just really exploring what I want. And I think the key thing, the key to confidence is exploring at first. Confidence is not something that just happens overnight. And it's not something that lasts forever. You have to constantly be cultivating your confidence.|||从那时起，我开始了真正探索自己想要的旅程。我认为最关键的一点，自信的关键在于首先去探索。自信不是一夜之间就能凭空产生的。它也不是一成不变、永远持续的。你必须不断地培养你的自信。
And I call it the confidence gym. Like, you have to be lifting weights. Like there are times like micro things that I still struggle with. When I'm the biggest girl in my workout class, sometimes I still want to keep my shirt on and not wear my sports bra. And I'm like, why are you doing that? Is it because you really don't want to do that? Or you scare people who are going to judge you?
And I call it the confidence gym. Like, you have to be lifting weights. Like there are times like micro things that I still struggle with. When I'm the biggest girl in my workout class, sometimes I still want to keep my shirt on and not wear my sports bra. And I'm like, why are you doing that? Is it because you really don't want to do that? Or you scare people who are going to judge you?|||我把它叫做“自信健身房”。就像你必须去举重一样。比如有时候，我仍然会为一些微小的事情感到纠结。当我是健身课上体型最胖的女孩时，有时我还是想穿着T恤不愿只穿运动内衣。然后我会对自己说：“你为什么要这么做？是因为你真的不想这样吗？还是因为你害怕别人对你评头论足？”
And then sometimes I'm like, oh, I'm at this gala with billionaires. And here I am like the trashy girl shaking ass. I'm like, am I going to like pretend that my name is Tiffany Wellington the 12? or am I just going to show up and be proud of who I am? So, you know, I think the thing is, is that never let other people's labels define you. And also, you can't, the biggest, there's this great quote that I really hold on to a lot of time is no one can make you feel inferior without your consent. So when it comes to being confident, a million people might have opinions of you, but the only one that truly matters is your own. And at the end of the day, it's a simple question.
And then sometimes I'm like, oh, I'm at this gala with billionaires. And here I am like the trashy girl shaking ass. I'm like, am I going to like pretend that my name is Tiffany Wellington the 12? or am I just going to show up and be proud of who I am? So, you know, I think the thing is, is that never let other people's labels define you. And also, you can't, the biggest, there's this great quote that I really hold on to a lot of time is no one can make you feel inferior without your consent. So when it comes to being confident, a million people might have opinions of you, but the only one that truly matters is your own. And at the end of the day, it's a simple question.|||然后有时我会想：“哦，我和亿万富翁们一起出席这个盛会。而我却像个低俗的女孩在这里扭动臀部。”我会想：“我是要假装自己叫蒂芬妮·威灵顿十二世呢，还是就大大方方地出现，为自己感到骄傲？”所以，你知道的，我认为关键在于：永远不要让别人的标签来定义你。另外，你不能...有一个我经常铭记在心的伟大名言：未经你的同意，没有人能让你感到自卑。所以说到自信，可能有上百万人对你有看法，但唯一真正重要的只有你自己的看法。归根结底，这是一个很简单的问题：
Are you going to let other people stop you from living the life that you want? Are you going to let opinion stop you from being you? And it's either a yes or no question. And once you finally face the fear of realizing, like, they just have opinions. Opinions aren't going to kill you. Like, I get hate comments all the time. I've had an article. I've had threads of people saying how ugly I am.
Are you going to let other people stop you from living the life that you want? Are you going to let opinion stop you from being you? And it's either a yes or no question. And once you finally face the fear of realizing, like, they just have opinions. Opinions aren't going to kill you. Like, I get hate comments all the time. I've had an article. I've had threads of people saying how ugly I am.|||你打算让别人阻止你过上自己想要的生活吗？你打算让别人的观点阻止你做真实的自己吗？这其实是一个非黑即白的问题。一旦你终于直面那种恐惧，意识到：他们不过是有各自的看法罢了。别人的看法是不会要了你的命的。比如，我一直都在收到恶评。我曾看到过一篇文章，看到过无数帖子在评论我有多丑。
I'm still out here and I'm still having fun. And I actually feel more confident because once it's almost like, once you face your fear of being ridiculed for your size or for your thoughts or whatever. whatever it is, you can't hate someone that's putting themselves out there. And it's better to be on the court playing the game than being what that. It's better to be on the court playing the game than observing and talking shit. Those that don't do talk shit. So be someone that does.
I'm still out here and I'm still having fun. And I actually feel more confident because once it's almost like, once you face your fear of being ridiculed for your size or for your thoughts or whatever. whatever it is, you can't hate someone that's putting themselves out there. And it's better to be on the court playing the game than being what that. It's better to be on the court playing the game than observing and talking shit. Those that don't do talk shit. So be someone that does.|||我依然活得好好的，也依然在享受生活。而且我实际上感觉更自信了，因为一旦...这就好比，一旦你直面了害怕因身材、想法或任何事情而被嘲笑的恐惧时，你就无法去讨厌一个敢于展现自我的人了。比起作壁上观，在球场上亲自比赛要好得多。比起作壁上观，在球场上亲自比赛要好得多，而不是站在场边冷眼旁观、说三道四。那些不做实事的人才只会说风凉话。所以，要做一个付诸行动的人。
And mind your business and be the best version of yourself. And then you don't care what people are saying because at least you're doing the things that you were born to do and that you love to do. I love that. That's like the pep talk that I honestly needed today. I'm like, yeah. Oh my God. I'm like getting hyped up. I'm like, yeah.
And mind your business and be the best version of yourself. And then you don't care what people are saying because at least you're doing the things that you were born to do and that you love to do. I love that. That's like the pep talk that I honestly needed today. I'm like, yeah. Oh my God. I'm like getting hyped up. I'm like, yeah.|||管好你自己的事，做最好的自己。然后你就不会在意别人在说些什么了，因为至少你在做那些你生来就该做、并且热爱去做的事情。我太喜欢这番话了。老实说，这就是我今天最需要的加油打气。我都忍不住想说：太对了！天哪。我整个人都被点燃了，心想：说得好！
Yeah, let's go. And I'm going to our tour. I'm going to do one soon. Like, I always do it. I honestly, like, totally agree with that. The quote that always, like, sticks out to me is, like, you are never going to be criticized by someone who is doing better than you. The people who are going to criticize you are always the ones who,
Yeah, let me go. And I'm going to our tour. I'm going to do one soon. Like, I always do it. I honestly, like, totally agree with that. The quote that always, like, sticks out to me is, like, you are never going to be criticized by someone who is doing better than you. The people who are going to criticize you are always the ones who,|||耶，冲吧！我也要参加我们的巡演了。我很快就会办一场。就像我一直做的那样。说实话，我真的、完全同意这一点。有一句名言一直让我印象深刻，那就是：永远不会有人过得比你好却来批评你。那些会批评你的人，永远是那些...
and if you think about it from your own perspective, like, we all judge people at times. Like, we all sometimes, like, have bad thoughts about people that we see in the street. I'm going to promise you. like 99% of the time that you have a negative judgmental thought about someone else, that is you projecting the feeling that you're feeling about yourself. If you see someone, you're like, why is she wearing that? Like, oh, like, she, her butt looks like kind of weird. That's because you would feel that way.
and if you think about it from your own perspective, like, we all judge people at times. Like, we all sometimes, like, have bad thoughts about people that we see in the street. I'm promising you. like 99% of the time that you have a negative judgmental thought about someone else, that is you projecting the feeling that you're feeling about yourself. If you see someone, you're like, why is she wearing that? Like, oh, like, she, her butt looks like kind of weird. That's because you would feel that way.|||而且如果你从自己的角度来想，比如，我们有时都会对别人评头论足。比如，我们有时会对在街上看到的人产生不好的想法。我向你保证。99%的情况下，当你对别人产生负面的评判性想法时，那其实都是你在投射你对自己内心的感受。如果你看到某个人，心想：“她为什么穿成那样？”或者“哦，她的屁股看起来有点奇怪。”那是因为你自己如果穿成那样，也会有这种感觉。
Like, that's an insecurity that you feel you would have in that outfit that you're projecting. Or if you're like, oh, like, you know, her makeup, like doesn't look blended. Like, whatever. 99% of the time, that comment that you want to make, about someone else is something that you feel insecure about yourself. And so I always think about that, Tiff, when I think about the comments that I also get. Mine are often less about my looks and more about like my opinions, which kind of fucking hurts sometimes, but like, I don't mind. But I'm like, you know what? I get it. Like, it's hard to put yourself out there, especially like online and not
Like, that's an insecurity that you feel you would have in that outfit that you're projecting. Or if you're like, oh, like, you know, her makeup, like doesn't look blended. Like, whatever. 99% of the time, that comment that you want to make, about someone else is something that you feel insecure about yourself. And so I always think about that, Tiff, when I think about the comments that I also get. Mine are often less about my looks and more about like my opinions, which kind of fucking hurts sometimes, but like, I don't mind. But I'm like, you know what? I get it. Like, it's hard to put yourself out there, especially like online and not|||这就好比，那是你觉得自己穿这套衣服时会产生的不安全感，而你把它投射出去了。或者如果你觉得：“哦，你知道吗，她的妆容看起来没晕染好。诸如此类。”99%的情况下，你想对别人说的那句刻薄评论，其实正是你对自己感到不自信的地方。所以蒂芙，每当我想到自己收到的那些评论时，我总是会想起这一点。我的评论往往较少涉及我的外表，更多是针对我的观点，这有时真的很他妈的伤人，但...我不在乎。不过我心想：你知道吗？我懂。把真实的自己毫无保留地展现出来是很难的，尤其是在网络上，要想不...
expect some people to find that like uncomfortable because they're uncomfortable with themselves. hurt people, hurt people. But you know what's going to hurt you more being afraid to be your full self? Like I think what's great is that as long as you're trying, people can comment because you're doing something cool. Haters are actually a sign that you're doing something right. And I think like once you're living your truth, like wearing that crazy outfit that you like, pursuing that job that everybody thinks is crazy to do, you really don't place as much value on their opinions because you start building the strength in yourself. and it overrides everything. So I think to view confidence as strength that you constantly are building, for me,
expect some people to find that like uncomfortable because they're uncomfortable with themselves. hurt people, hurt people. But you know what's going to hurt you more being afraid to be your full self? Like I think what's great is that as long as you're trying, people can comment because you're doing something cool. Haters are actually a sign that you're doing something right. And I think like once you're living your truth, like wearing that crazy outfit that you like, pursuing that job that everybody thinks is crazy to do, you really don't place as much value on their opinions because you start building the strength in yourself. and it overrides everything. So I think to view confidence as strength that you constantly are building, for me,|||指望所有人都接受是很困难的，因为他们对自己感到不自在。受过伤的人往往会去伤害别人。但你知道什么会更伤你吗？那就是害怕做完整的自己。我觉得最棒的一点是，只要你在尝试，人们就会评头论足，因为你在做一些酷炫的事情。黑粉其实正是你做对了事情的标志。而且我认为，一旦你开始活出真实的自我——比如穿上你喜欢的那套夸张衣服，去追求一份在所有人看来都极其疯狂的工作——你就不会再那么看重别人的看法了，因为你开始在内心构建力量，而这种力量会凌驾于一切之上。所以我认为，把自信看作是你不断构建的力量，对我而言...
like the beginning stages of confidence are making choices that align with who you want to be. So even if, like, right now, you're like, oh, I'm really shy. I don't like myself. I feel ugly. I don't think I'm funny. I don't think I'm smart. You can make the list. What I would recommend, like, it's just truly a pragmatic thing that I still do is, like,
like the beginning stages of confidence are making choices that align with who you want to be. So even if, like, right now, you're like, oh, I'm really shy. I don't like myself. I feel ugly. I don't think I'm funny. I don't think I'm smart. You can make the list. What I would recommend, like, it's just truly a pragmatic thing that I still do is, like,|||自信的初级阶段就是做出与你想成为的人相契合的选择。所以即使像现在，你可能会觉得：“哦，我真的很害羞。我不喜欢自己。我觉得自己很丑。我觉得自己一点也不幽默。我觉得自己不够聪明。”你可以列出这样一张清单。而我推荐的做法——这真的是一个我至今仍在使用的实用方法——就是...
a confidence check-in, right? Everything that you've paid about yourself right now. And then you say, what would a person do that wasn't doing that? So like, for example, if you don't like that, you always are wearing beige, you want to wear yellow, but you're so scared. In your mind, be like, who is a type of person that wears yellow? Samantha Jones. What would Samantha Jones do in this situation?
a confidence check-in, right? Everything that you've paid about yourself right now. And then you say, what would a person do that wasn't doing that? So like, for example, if you don't like that, you always are wearing beige, you want to wear yellow, but you're so scared. In your mind, be like, who is a type of person that wears yellow? Samantha Jones. What would Samantha Jones do in this situation?|||进行一次自信打卡，对吧？审视你刚刚对自己的所有批判。然后你问自己：一个没有这种自卑心理的人会怎么做？所以，举个例子，如果你不喜欢自己总是穿米色，你想穿黄色，但又害怕得要命。在脑海里设想一下：什么样的人会穿黄色？萨曼莎·琼斯。在这种情况下，萨曼莎·琼斯会怎么做？
You know what I mean? So start to embody mentally the person that could do the things that you want to do and that are fearless. And then I think the biggest thing that has stopped my growth and what I saw that has stopped a few of my client's growth is that it's the fear. It's not even the actual doing it. You spend so much time in this anxiety purgatory just like envisioning how bad it's going to be. But then when you actually do it, it's not even close. It's actually like everyone, I guarantee you if someone, if you wear that yellow, you're going to have 20 people come up to you and be like, oh my God, you look great.
You know what I mean? So start to embody mentally the person that could do the things that you want to do and that are fearless. And then I think the biggest thing that has stopped my growth and what I saw that has stopped a few of my client's growth is that it's the fear. It's not even the actual doing it. You spend so much time in this anxiety purgatory just like envisioning how bad it's going to be. But then when you actually do it, it's not even close. It's actually like everyone, I guarantee you if someone, if you wear that yellow, you're going to have 20 people come up to you and be like, oh my God, you look great.|||你知道我的意思吗？所以，开始在精神上具象化那个能够做你想做的事情并且无所畏惧的人。然后我认为，阻碍我成长以及我看到阻碍我的一些客户成长的最大因素，其实是恐惧。甚至都不是实际去做这件事本身。你花了大量的时间处于这种焦虑的炼狱中，只是在脑海里想象事情会有多糟糕。但当你真正去做了之后，发现根本不是那么回事。实际上，每个人...我向你保证，如果有人、如果你穿了那身黄色的衣服，会有20个人走到你面前说：“天哪，你看起来棒极了。”
Yeah. You know? It's really our head. stopping us from being the version that we want to be a lot of the times. Well, it's the idea of like the what if thinking, which is like a huge sign of anxiety. If a thought starts with what if, it's an anxious thought. And the one that always comes up is like,
Yeah. You know? It's really our head. stopping us from being the version that we want to be a lot of the times. Well, it's the idea of like the what if thinking, which is like a huge sign of anxiety. If a thought starts with what if, it's an anxious thought. And the one that always comes up is like,|||是的。你知道吗？很多时候，阻碍我们成为理想中的自己的，其实正是我们自己的大脑。好吧，这就是那种“如果...怎么办”的思维模式，这是焦虑的一个巨大标志。如果一个想法以“如果...怎么办”开头，它就是一个焦虑的想法。而最常出现的想法就是...
what if people don't like me? What if people judge me? What if they find me less attractive? What if they think I'm too much? And then you follow that with another what if. And this is how I always count on those thoughts. So like, what if that person finds me less attractive because I decided to wear what I wanted to wear? And then you go, okay, and then what? What is the consequence of that?
what if people don't like me? What if people judge me? What if they find me less attractive? What if they think I'm too much? And then you follow that with another what if. And this is how I always count on those thoughts. So like, what if that person finds me less attractive because I decided to wear what I wanted to wear? And then you go, okay, and then what? What is the consequence of that?|||如果人们不喜欢我怎么办？如果人们对评头论足怎么办？如果他们觉得我不再那么有吸引力了怎么办？如果他们觉得我太过了怎么办？然后你又会紧接着冒出另一个“如果...怎么办”。这就是我应对这些想法的方式。比如，如果那个人因为我决定穿我想穿的衣服而觉得我吸引力下降了怎么办？然后你会想：好吧，那又怎样？这会带来什么后果？
And then what happens after that? Well, then they don't find me attractive so they don't want to keep dating me. And then what? Well, then, you know, we break up. And then what? You find someone better. Like, if you follow, like, an anxious thought to its, like, logical end, you always, like, come out at a better solution. You always come out of a point where you're like, actually, this really doesn't matter that much. Like, it really doesn't matter. And you know, I love that at Trinathon. I always follow that, too. And, like, on top of that, it's also just like, when you're being your full self,
And then what happens after that? Well, then they don't find me attractive so they don't want to keep dating me. And then what? Well, then, you know, we break up. And then what? You find someone better. Like, if you follow, like, an anxious thought to its, like, logical end, you always, like, come out at a better solution. You always come out of a point where you're like, actually, this really doesn't matter that much. Like, it really doesn't matter. And you know, I love that at Trinathon. I always follow that, too. And, like, on top of that, it's also just like, when you're being your full self,|||那之后会发生什么？嗯，然后他们觉得我没有吸引力了，所以不想继续跟我约会了。然后呢？嗯，然后，你知道的，我们分手了。然后呢？你会找到更好的人。如果你把一个焦虑的想法推演到它的逻辑终点，你总是能得出一个更好的解决方案。你总是会得出这样一个结论：其实，这真的没那么重要。这真的无所谓。你知道吗，我在参与 Trinathon 时非常喜欢这一点。我一直也是这么做的。而且除此之外，这也就像是，当你毫无保留地做真实的自己时...
you're going to lose a lot of people that wanted the wrong version of you. And you have to be okay with that. Like, you know, I've changed a lot in my middle 20s. I used to be the girl that was out and about all the time, partying all the time. And I woke up one day and I was like, you know, I want a real career. I want real love. I want to feel good about myself. I want to feel positive.
you're going to lose a lot of people that wanted the wrong version of you. And you have to be okay with that. Like, you know, I've changed a lot in my middle 20s. I used to be the girl that was out and about all the time, partying all the time. And I woke up one day and I was like, you know, I want a real career. I want real love. I want to feel good about myself. I want to feel positive.|||你会失去许多那些想要错误版本的你的人。你必须接受这一点。比如，你知道的，我在20多岁中期发生了很大变化。我曾经是一个整天在外闲逛、成天泡吧的女孩。直到有一天我醒悟过来，心想：你知道吗，我想要一份真正的职业。我想要真正的爱情。我想要对自己感觉良好。我想要保持积极向上。
I just don't want to be the chaotic friend that has the funny stories. Like I don't want to live for the story anymore. I want to write my own story. And I did lose a lot of friends. And, you know, I think one thing I really want to talk about, I feel like this is like probably the first place that I've discussed this, but it feels like the right place is that just because you're confident doesn't mean that you're not anxious.
I just don't want to be the chaotic friend that has the funny stories. Like I don't want to live for the story anymore. I want to write my own story. And I did lose a lot of friends. And, you know, I think one thing I really want to talk about, I feel like this is like probably the first place that I've discussed this, but it feels like the right place is that just because you're confident doesn't mean that you're not anxious.|||我再也不想当那个只有搞笑故事、生活一团糟的朋友了。我不想再为故事而活了。我想书写我自己的故事。我的确失去了很多朋友。而且，你知道的，我觉得有一件事我真的很想聊聊，感觉这大概是我第一次公开讨论这个，但这里似乎是个最合适的地方：仅仅因为你很自信，并不意味着你不焦虑。
It doesn't mean that you don't have crippling self-doubt. It doesn't mean that you are invincible. I have insane anxiety that I've struggled with for years. And, you know, I think what gets me through all of these things is having these sacred things that I do that are just mine. And it's like whether people like me or not, these are the things that I stand for. Like, these are the things that make me happy to be who I am. And I think cultivating those things help you have that tenacity when other people's opinions get in the way. So the way that I think is like, you're, you're, you're, your reason for being alive, your motivation, and it shouldn't be chasing likes or opinions or validation
It doesn't mean that you don't have crippling self-doubt. It doesn't mean that you are invincible. I have insane anxiety that I've struggled with for years. And, you know, I think what gets me through all of these things is having these sacred things that I do that are just mine. And it's like whether people like me or not, these are the things that I stand for. Like, these are the things that make me happy to be who I am. And I think cultivating those things help you have that tenacity when other people's opinions get in the way. So the way that I think is like, you're, you're, you're, your reason for being alive, your motivation, and it shouldn't be chasing likes or opinions or validation|||这并不意味着你没有那种令人崩溃的自我怀疑。这并不意味着你是无敌的。我有着极其严重的焦虑症，多年来一直在与之抗争。而且，你知道的，我认为让我挺过这一切的是那些我专属的神圣事物。这就好比无论别人是否喜欢我，这些都是我所坚守的东西。这些都是让我为自己是谁而感到快乐的事情。我认为培养这些兴趣可以帮助你在面对别人的非议时拥有那种坚韧。所以我的想法是：你生存的理由、你的动力，不应该去追逐点赞、别人的看法或认可...
or men. It should be like, I want to make this change in the world. I want to make this change in myself. And I want to love that it's going to change me for the better. All the other stuff is just noise. And people can't take things from you that are simply yours. And that could be something as small as journaling. I've journaled my whole life or reading these books that you start your day with, you know so the key to confidence in those small ways are picking things that are yours that have nothing to do with anyone else whether it's meditating or things like that and really embodying that as your identity outside of the world's noise one for me is like boxing i used to treat it's really interesting when i was going to talk about it later but maybe we talk about it now like
or men. It should be like, I want to make this change in the world. I want to make this change in myself. And I want to love that it's going to change me for the better. All the other stuff is just noise. And people can't take things from you that are simply yours. And that could be something as small as journaling. I've journaled my whole life or reading these books that you start your day with, you know so the key to confidence in those small ways are picking things that are yours that have nothing to do with anyone else whether it's meditating or things like that and really embodying that as your identity outside of the world's noise one for me is like boxing i used to treat it's really interesting when i was going to talk about it later but maybe we talk about it now like|||或是追求男人。而应该是：我想为这个世界带来改变。我想在自己身上做出这种改变。并且我乐于看到它让我变得更好。其他所有的事情都只是噪声。而且别人无法夺走那些纯粹属于你的东西。那可以是一件小到写日记的事。我一辈子都在写日记，或者读那些开启你一天的书，你知道的...所以建立自信的关键在于那些微小的方式：挑选那些完全属于你、与其他人毫无关系的事情，无论是冥想还是诸如此类的事，并真正将其内化为你在喧嚣世界之外的身份认同。对我来说，其中一项就是拳击。我以前对待...很有趣，我本来打算晚点再聊这个，但也许我们现在就可以聊聊...
the interactions between like exercise and confidence previously it used to be such like a one-way straight for me, which was like, exercise means weight loss, means more confidence. And now I was talking to a friend about it and I was like, it's so crazy how like in the last couple of years my relationship to exercise and physical activity has been more about like a way to express love for my body and a way to like see how my body moves and and to treat it well. And right now I'm like obsessed with boxing. There is something so satisfying about like punching a bag again and again. yeah a jab cross baby nothing better yeah honestly it's like it makes me feel so powerful so it's
the interactions between like exercise and confidence previously it used to be such like a one-way straight for me, which was like, exercise means weight loss, means more confidence. And now I was talking to a friend about it and I was like, it's so crazy how like in the last couple of years my relationship to exercise and physical activity has been more about like a way to express love for my body and a way to like see how my body moves and and to treat it well. And right now I'm like obsessed with boxing. There is something so satisfying about like punching a bag again and again. yeah a jab cross baby nothing better yeah honestly it's like it makes me feel so powerful so it's|||比如运动与自信之间的互动。以前对我来说，这似乎是一个单行道，也就是：运动意味着减重，意味着更多的自信。而现在，我和一个朋友聊起这个时我说：太疯狂了，在过去几年里，我对运动和体力活动的态度已经变成了一种表达对身体之爱的途径，一种观察我的身体如何运动并善待它的方式。现在我简直迷上了拳击。一次又一次地击打沙袋，那种感觉简直太满足了。没错，一记直拳接交叉拳，宝贝，没有什么比这更棒了。是的，老实说，这让我觉得自己充满力量，所以...
like those little activities i think are amazing when you're like this is just for me i'm not trying to become like a fucking mma fighter like i'm not trying to like become an author i'm not trying to like become a writer like i'm just doing this because like you said no one can take something from you that is truly yours and that is only yours which i think is such a powerful way of putting it yeah and you know I think what you're saying, like, with the exercise is so beautiful because there's so many different ways to do it. Like, when you talk about confidence in size, I think there's no way to, like, have this conversation without discussing how we view our bodies comes to play. Some of my clients that actually fit the, quote, unquote, beauty standards so perfectly have so much insecurity. And then some people that have different body struggles or that you think would have,
like those little activities i think are amazing when you're like this is just for me i'm not trying to become like a fucking mma fighter like i'm not trying to like become an author i'm not trying to like become a writer like i'm just doing this because like you said no one can take something from you that is truly yours and that is only yours which i think is such a powerful way of putting it yeah and you know I think what you're saying, like, with the exercise is so beautiful because there's so many different ways to do it. Like, when you talk about confidence in size, I think there's no way to, like, have this conversation without discussing how we view our bodies comes to play. Some of my clients that actually fit the, quote, unquote, beauty standards so perfectly have so much insecurity. And then some people that have different body struggles or that you think would have,|||我觉得这些小型活动太棒了，当你的心态是“这纯粹是为了我自己，我可不是想成为什么他妈的综合格斗选手，我也不想当什么作家，我不想成为什么写书的人，我做这个纯粹是因为，就像你说的，没有人能从你手中夺走那些真正属于你、只属于你的东西”，我觉得这种说法太有力量了。是的，而且你知道，我觉得你刚才关于运动的说法非常美妙，因为有太多不同的方式来做到这一点。比如，当你谈到对身材的自信时，我认为在讨论这个话题时，绝对绕不开我们如何看待自己的身体。我的一些客户，她们明明完美符合所谓的“美丽标准”，却有着严重的不安全感。而另一些有着不同的身材困扰、或者你以为她们会...
different body starters are the most confident people in the world. But I think the biggest thing is that, you know, we all have different sizes. We all have different goals. We all view ourselves in different lights. But I think the biggest thing that's helped my confidence, again, as always being perceived as like the big girl and being put down for it a lot. Like I really, my old perception when I was dating was like, oh my God, I'm so lucky that a guy would want to date someone in my size. That was really how I I felt. And I think it's, it's hard to discuss it, but I feel like at the same time, it's probably something that a lot of people, especially in their early 20s, deal with, because you're thrown into this dating world. You don't have a lot of experience. And especially if you've been bullied,
different body starters are the most confident people in the world. But I think the biggest thing is that, you know, we all have different sizes. We all have different goals. We all view ourselves in different lights. But I think the biggest thing that's helped my confidence, again, as always being perceived as like the big girl and being put down for it a lot. Like I really, my old perception when I was dating was like, oh my God, I'm so lucky that a guy would want to date someone in my size. That was really how I I felt. And I think it's, it's hard to discuss it, but I feel like at the same time, it's probably something that a lot of people, especially in their early 20s, deal with, because you're thrown into this dating world. You don't have a lot of experience. And especially if you've been bullied,|||身材烦恼的人，反而是世界上最自信的人。但我认为最重要的一点是，你知道的，我们都有着不同的体型。我们都有不同的目标。我们都以不同的眼光看待自己。但我认为对我自信心帮助最大的是——再次强调，我一直被视为“大码女孩”，并因此经常受到贬低。比如我以前在约会时的旧观念是：“天哪，居然有男生愿意和像我这样身材的人约会，我太幸运了。”这真的是我当时的真实感受。我觉得这很难启齿，但同时我也觉得，这可能是许多人——尤其是20岁出头的人——正在经历的事情，因为你被直接抛进了这个约会世界。你没有太多的经验。尤其是如果你曾遭受过欺凌，
your self-esteem is in the gutter. It is below sea level. So it's not, wow, he's lucky to be in my life. It's like, wow, I'm lucky to even get a guy to text me at 4 a.m. I'm lucky to get a guy that will make me an option. But the biggest thing is, like, we don't deserve just to be an option. and we deserve to be the one. And the way to do that, though, is by setting that standard. Because, you know, right now, I, like, of course, every day is a different day with my confidence journey. I've kind of taken my whole identity outside of what I think men want me to be or what I think the world wants me to be.
your self-esteem is in the gutter. It is below sea level. So it's not, wow, he's lucky to be in my life. It's like, wow, I'm lucky to even get a guy to text me at 4 a.m. I'm lucky to get a guy that will make me an option. But the biggest thing is, like, we don't deserve just to be an option. and we deserve to be the one. And the way to do that, though, is by setting that standard. Because, you know, right now, I, like, of course, every day is a different day with my confidence journey. I've kind of taken my whole identity outside of what I think men want me to be or what I think the world wants me to be.|||你的自尊心简直跌入了谷底。低到了海平面以下。所以心态不是“哇，他能进入我的生活真是他的幸运”，而是“哇，我居然能让一个男生在凌晨4点给我发信息，我太幸运了。我居然能让一个男生把我当成一个备选项，我太幸运了。”但最重要的事情是，我们不应该仅仅成为一个备选项，我们值得成为那个无可替代的唯一。而要做到这一点的方法，就是树立起这个标准。因为，你知道的，现在我...当然，我的自信之旅每天都在发生变化。我已经把我的整个身份认同从“我认为男人希望我成为的样子”或“我认为世界希望我成为的样子”之中彻底剥离出来了。
But you can't deny that, like, it's sometimes challenging when you're not really, like, how do I say this? Like back when I was really serial dating, it was all about being sexy. It was all about dressing for the male gaze. And now I'm not really doing that. I'm wearing things that make me feel sexy. So I'm not getting as much, you know, attention from men in that way. Actually, the last like five guys I've gone our date with, they like want to be business partners. I'm like, is this the energy I'm giving with my power suits? Are you serious? That is so funny. I honestly be like, yes. Absolutely. Here we go. But it's again that thing where you're building that confidence of being like,
但你不能否认，比如，有时候当你不是真的，比如，我该怎么说呢？就像以前我真的在疯狂约会的时候，一切都是为了性感。一切都是为了迎合男性的凝视。而现在我不再那样做了。我穿那些让我感觉性感的衣服。所以我从男性那里得到的，你知道的，那种关注没有那么多了。事实上，最近和我约会的五个男生，他们都想成为商业伙伴。我在想，这就是我穿权力套装散发出的能量吗？你是认真的吗？太搞笑了。老实说，我会觉得，是的。绝对的。这就来。但这也是那种建立自信的过程，让你觉得，
I don't want to draw the wrong people towards me. And if I'm, you know, dressing in a way or doing things that don't embody who I really am and I'm doing this because I think that's what they like, that's actually hurting your confidence in the end because then you're not building it from a place of your own power. You're building it from a place of what you think others want. Oh, I completely get what you mean. It's also this really interesting thing where it's like, especially if you were someone
我不想把错的人吸引到我身边。如果我，你知道的，穿着某种风格，或者做一些并不真正体现自我本色的事情，而我这么做是因为我认为那是他们喜欢的，这最终其实会损害你的自信，因为那样的话，你的自信就不是建立在你自己力量的基础上。而是建立在你以为别人想要什么的基础上。哦，我完全明白你的意思。这也是一件非常有趣的事，就是说，特别是如果你是一个人
who perhaps didn't like, People didn't really, like, show you that they were attracted to. When you, you know, they didn't really show you, like, admiration or attraction when you were, like, in high school. Or even in college. Like, I remember being in high school and, like, no one ever really, like, had a crush on me. No one really was, like, ever, like, God, she's, like, attractive. Like, no one really, like, flooded with me. And, you know, all of my other friends had, like, boyfriends and, like, little flings.
也许并不喜欢，人们其实并没有，比如，向你表现出他们被你吸引。当你在，你知道的，当你在高中时，他们并没有真正向你表达，比如，崇拜或吸引。甚至在大学里也一样。比如，我记得在高中时，根本没有人真正，比如，对我有过好感。没有人真的，比如，觉得，天哪，她好有吸引力。真的没有人，比如，对我献殷勤。而且，你知道的，我所有的其他朋友都有，比如，男朋友和，比如，小恋情。
And, like, they had that, like, teenage love experience. and I didn't really have that the same way that they did. And so then when I like went to uni and then even when I like left uni and moved to like a big city, it was like anyone who was willing to give me an inch was going to get a mile from me. Like I was like, yes, please. I'm like a freaking foster home. Like please drop off your neglected male pets. Like and I will gladly take them because I'm, I want. intimacy and I want compassion.
而且，比如，她们有过那种，比如，少男少女恋爱的经历。而我并没有真正以她们那种方式经历过。所以后来当我上大学，甚至离开大学搬到大城市之后，任何愿意向我施舍一点好感的人，都会从我这里得到极大的回应。比如我就觉得，好啊，求之不得。我简直就像个收容所。比如，请把你们被忽视的男性宠物都送来。比如，我会欣然接受，因为我渴望。亲密感，我渴望同情。
And then it's about being like, you said this in terms of like showing up to your dates in power suits. It was like, all right, I'm going to stop thinking that like the biggest prize here is for this person to like me. And the prize is going to be for me to actually like walk out of that date and like myself. And I'm actually going to be thinking about whether I like the day. Exactly. Like you need to flip it to be like, I am a judge on American Idol and they're a contestant. Like I'm here to see if they're going to make the cut. Dance for me.
然后这就变成了，就像你刚才说的，穿着权力套装去约会。这就好比，好吧，我要停止认为这里最大的奖赏是让这个人喜欢我。而真正的奖赏应该是，我能真正昂首阔步地离开那场约会，并且喜欢我自己。而且我会去思考我是否真的喜欢这次约会。没错了！就像你需要把视角反转过来，觉得自己是《美国偶像》的评委，而他们是参赛选手。我来这里就是为了看看他们能不能过关。为我跳舞。
Do a sing. Do a dance. I need to be entertained. But I think a lot of people struggle, especially a lot of young women. It's like you feel like you have to chase someone in order for them to like you. And I think that all comes from the places of like this crazy bullshit timeline. You know, it's like you feel like you're missing out if you're not in a serious relationship by 21 or 22. Or again, like you said, didn't have that high school fling.
唱个歌。跳个舞。我需要被娱乐。但我认为很多人都在苦苦挣扎，尤其是很多年轻女性。就好像你觉得自己必须去追逐某人，才能让他们喜欢你。而且我认为这一切都源于那种疯狂的、扯淡的时间线。你知道的，就好像如果你在21或22岁时还没有一段认真的恋爱，你就会觉得自己错过了什么。或者就像你刚才说的，没有经历过高中的恋情。
That timeline is so fake. And it doesn't exist and you can still be happy being 26 with a nice little puppy and going on dates and taking time. You know, you don't become a surgeon after one day of class. It things, good things you have to work towards. Good things take time. And yes, there's some relationships where you meet in a cute supermarket and you find a love of your life and you're happily ever after. But for most of us, it's going through the ups and downs of the dating apps. It's going, putting yourself out there. But every time you put yourself out there, you learn a little bit about what you want and more importantly
那种时间线太虚假了。它根本不存在，26岁时养只可爱的小狗，去约会，慢慢来，你同样可以过得很开心。你知道的，你不可能上了一天课就变成外科医生。有些事情，美好的事物需要你为之努力。美好的事物需要时间。是的，有些关系是你在一个浪漫的超市里遇到，找到了你的一生挚爱，从此幸福快乐地生活在一起。但对于我们大多数人来说，都要经历约会软件上的起起伏伏。去经历，去勇敢地展现自己。但每次你勇敢地展现自己，你就会对自己想要的东西有更多了解，更重要的是
what you don't want and the fact that you're walking away from the things that you don't want are actually making you a better version of yourself because every time you say no to things that hurt you, you're saying yes to the future version of you and building a more confident version of you. Oh my gosh, that was so powerful.
对你不需要的东西有更多了解，而且你正在远离那些你不需要的东西，这实际上正在让你成为更好的自己，因为每次你对那些伤害你的事情说不，你就是在对未来的自己说yes，并建立一个更自信的自己。哦天哪，太有力量了。
I'm not screaming me on. Oh my God. I'm like this is like really giving me a bit of a wake-up cult if I'm like overwhelmed. But also like the people need to hear it. The people need hear it. I honestly think that like we've spoken about this a little bit as well but sometimes we worry about the people that are going to leave our lives when we start to embody confidence more and for sure that does happen like especially people in like who you're like
我简直要尖叫了。天哪。我觉得这真的给了我一种醍醐灌顶的感觉，虽然让我有点应接不暇。但大家也确实需要听到这些。大家真的需要听到这些。老实说，我觉得我们之前也稍微聊过这个，但有时我们会担心，当我们开始真正展现自信时，那些会离开我们生活的人，肯定的，这种情况确实会发生，尤其是那些你，比如
kind of romantically invested in who are like what do you mean I can't just walk all over you? Like oh god but you will lose people however I think that I I also was quite bullied in primary school and in high school. And I've realized that nothing could be as bad as that. So I've kind of taught myself to not feel embarrassment. And the moment that I stopped caring about what other people thought, especially people who didn't love me and just let myself be authentic, suddenly I actually had more friends than I've ever had.
在感情上有些投入的人，他们会觉得，什么意思？我怎么就不能对你为所欲为啦？哦天哪，虽然你会失去一些人，但我认为，我在小学和高中时也曾遭受过相当严重的霸凌。我意识到，没有什么能比那更糟糕了。所以我基本上已经教会了自己不再感到尴尬。而当我不再在乎别人的看法，尤其是那些不爱我的人的看法，只是让自己做最真实的自己时，突然间，我 faktisk 拥有了比以往任何时候都多的朋友。
And I had more people wanting to be with me. I felt like a magnet. It was kind of like the moment that you step into your power and are like, this is who I am either like it or I'm not interested. People love that. That is so freaking magnetic and powerful. Like, I think confidence is literally like life secret hack to attracting what you want. Have you found that like not just with dating, but like in your career, in your friendships, etc?
而且有更多的人想要和我在一起。我感觉自己就像一块磁铁。这就有点像当你真正进入自己的状态，然后说：这就是我，要么接受，要么免谈。人们非常喜欢这种态度。这简直太有磁性和力量了。我觉得自信简直就是生活中吸引你想要的东西的秘密武器。你有没有发现，不仅是在约我的过程中，在你的职业生涯、你的友谊中等等，也是如此？
My life in the last three years since I, again, I told you I had that epiphany that like I need to start being the real me and not chasing the things that are. just temporary fixes. My life has changed 100%. Three years ago, I was a dishwasher, a hostess, a struggling model. And then when I started the TikTok journey, you know, my first few videos going viral, I was shocked. And I, and it was a choice that I was like, am I going to leap into this totally scary, unknown world and shoot for something better? Or am I going to stay with my old ways that, you know, haven't done, aren't serving me anymore? Am I going to stay with that group of friends that are not serving me anymore or am I going to risk it all and try and be the version of myself that I know I could be. So I've always, again, since making that, even when I was in my
在过去三年的生活中，自从我，就像我刚才说的，我有了那个顿悟，意识到我需要开始做真实的自己，而不是去追逐那些。只是权宜之计的东西。我的生活发生了100%的改变。三年前，我是一个洗碗工、迎宾员、一个苦苦挣扎的模特。然后当我开始TikTok之旅时，你知道的，我的前几个视频居然火了，我当时震惊了。然后，这是一个选择，我在想：我是要跳进这个完全可怕、未知的世界去争取更好的东西？还是留在我的老路上，你知道的，那些已经不再适合我、不再为我服务的方式？我是要留在那个不再适合我的朋友圈里，还是放手一搏，去尝试成为那个我知道自己本可以成为的那个版本的自己？所以我一直以来，同样地，自从做出那个决定后，甚至当我还在
early 20s, I just loved learning about people. And I think that's like a great tip that I could give if you're just starting to cultivate your confidence. If you just start to open the conversation up, you'll realize that a lot of people are not as scary as you've built them to be in your head. And you also get rejected in the process, which will then make you realize that rejection is not going to kill you, babe. You know, it's actually, it's like exposure therapy. Like when you go get your latte, rather than having your headphones on and being like, you know, I'm scared, like that hopperista, I don't know what to say. Say, hey, be like, hey, thank you so much. This latte art is amazing. And then he'll end up talking about his dog or, you know, you'll start chatting. And I think realizing
二十岁出头的时候，我就很喜欢了解不同的人。我认为这是一个很好的建议，如果你刚开始培养自信的话。如果你只是开始打开对话，你会发现很多人并不像你在脑海中构建的那样可怕。而且在这个过程中你也会被拒绝，这会让你意识到，拒绝是不会杀死你的，宝贝。你知道的，这其实，这就像暴露疗法。就像你去买拿铁的时候，与其戴着耳机，心里想着，你知道的，我很害怕，那个咖啡师，我不知道该说什么。不如说，嘿，打个招呼，说：嘿，非常感谢。这个拿铁拉花太棒了。然后他最后可能会聊起他的狗，或者，你知道的，你们就聊起来了。而且我认为意识到
that like again you're on the same page as everyone else there's no one better than you and there's no one less than you and treat people with that same respect will gravitate that same respect towards you um i think a lot of times it's very easy and i i did this too where like you know the cool girl syndrome or all those you know you see these ticot trends of these girls especially now and now it is harder than ever to be confident because you're seeing the illusion of digital confidence that may not exist behind the screen. So I want everyone that is intaking content to please keep that in mind, you know, that girl that's walking in the street as confident.
就像我说的，你和其他所有人都在同一水平线上，没有人比你更好，也没有人比你更差，用同样的尊重对待别人，也会为你吸引来同样的尊重。嗯，我觉得很多时候这很容易发生，我以前也这样做过，比如，所谓的“酷女孩综合征”，或者所有这些，你知道的，你会看到这些关于这些女孩的TikTok潮流，尤其是现在，现在要保持自信比以往任何时候都难，因为你看到的是数字自信的幻觉，而这种自信在屏幕背后可能根本不存在。所以我希望每一个接收内容的人都能把这一点记在心里，你知道的，那个在街上走路显得很自信的女孩。
You don't know who that really is. It's a 15-second video. And you can't build confidence in 15 seconds. And anyone that's going to tell you that is lying. So the thing is how you start to build it over time. That's the thing. Give it time. Start talking to people.
你并不知道她真实的样子是什么。那只是一个15秒的视频。你不可能在15秒内建立自信。任何告诉你这件事的人都在撒谎。所以关键在于你如何随着时间一点点建立它。就是这样。给它时间。开始和人交流。
Start being like, I have a story that I want to share. and I also want to hear other people's stories too. And then it builds this beautiful chemistry that then you walk through life, not as someone proving, but someone that's curious. And then again, simple tip, people love to talk about themselves. You open that door and you're going to make friends with everybody. And again, once you start talking to people, you're going to realize, like, I'm interesting too.
开始说：我有一个故事想分享。我也想听听别人的故事。然后这就建立了一种美好的化学反应，接着你走过人生，不再是一个需要向别人证明自己的人，而是一个充满好奇心的人。然后还是那个简单的提示，人们总是喜欢谈论自己。你打开这扇门，就会和每个人都成为朋友。同样，一旦你开始和人们交谈，你就会意识到，其实我也很有趣。
So it starts, there's a lot of work that you do behind the scenes, right? Like journaling your insecurities, like saying, this is what I'm struggling with. I don't like how this looks or I don't like how I say this, this, this is, this. A lot of times we're hypercritical over ourselves and nobody notices these things anyway. But the second thing, I would say do a friend audit. If you have friends in your life that are talking down to you, making you feel like shit or being like, oh, are you going to wear something like that?
所以这一切的开始，你在幕后做了很多工作，对吧？比如把你的不安全感写进日记里，比如直言：这就是我正在挣扎的地方。我不喜欢我这个样子，或者我不喜欢我这样说话。很多时候，我们对自己过于苛刻，而根本没有人会注意到这些事情。但第二点，我会建议做一次“朋友审计”。如果你的生活中有那些贬低你、让你感觉像个垃圾，或者说“哦，你打算穿成这样吗？”的朋友。
Cut, cancel, delete. That is truly poisonous for your confidence journey. So do a friend audit and then be very open about putting yourself out there and putting yourself into new experiences. The things that's scary you should go towards a little bit more, especially if it's like new activities, new friends, like join that kickball league, join a pottery class, write that fucking play. You know, the things that you've been putting off because you're too scared to do,
剪掉，取消，删除。这对你的自信之旅来说绝对是毒药。所以做一次朋友审计，然后敞开心扉去展现自己，去体验新的事物。那些让你感到害怕的事情，你应该稍微多去尝试一点，特别是如果是新的活动、新的朋友，比如加入那个踢球俱乐部，参加陶艺课，去写那个该死的剧本。你知道的，那些你因为太害怕而一直搁置的事情，
you just start today, one hour, you know? All 30 minutes. Five, five, whatever. Literally just do it. Sponsored by Nike. Yeah, sponsored by Nike. Just kidding. The other thing I always think about, which is more like this is like a mental,
今天就开始做，花一个小时，你知道的？或者30分钟。5分钟，5分钟，随便什么。字面意思，直接去做。由耐克赞助。对，由耐克赞助。开玩笑的。另外一件我经常想的事，这更像是一种心理上的，
I don't know if you do this as well, but it's like a mental exercise. When I, when I used to like walk into a first day, when I'd walk in, when I now walk into like a room of new people, I imagine this like big golden bubble around me. And every time I breathe, it like comes out of my heart and it's like this big glittery bubble that everyone else can see. And I'm just like, I'm just expelling this like insane magnetic confidence, like this confident force. and that like visualization of myself as this like magnetic golden sparkling orb is so powerful and like just changing how I hold myself and the energy I give off and people respond to your energy if that's why like fake it to make it so correct like psychologically because people are going to mirror your behavior back to you if you are
我不知道你是不是也这样，但这就像是一个心理练习。当我，当我以前走进第一天的工作，当我现在走进一个充满陌生人的房间时，我会在自己周围想象这样一个巨大的金色泡泡。每次我呼吸，它就会从我的心脏扩散开来，就像一个所有人都能看到的巨大的、闪闪发光的泡泡。而我就会想，我正在散发这种疯狂的、磁性的自信，就像一股自信的力量。而这种将自己可视化为一个磁性的、金色的、闪闪发光的球体的视觉化练习是如此强大，并且改变了我的仪态以及我散发出的能量，人们会对你的能量做出回应，这就是为什么“假装直到你成功”在心理学上是如此正确，因为人们会把你的行为反射回给你，如果你在
telling them to treat you in a certain way i.e as it's someone who is a confident person they will do that that's the only thing they have to go off is how the version of yourself you choose to put out. Yeah, there's a quote. In order to, in order, in order to be successful, you must present an image of success at all times, right? That was like a business thing that I heard. Because, you know, I think it's very scary in our 20s because it's like, we kind of don't know what the fuck we're doing. And we're supposed to have all this pressure to be like, oh, I'm going to get an A in my university and I'm going to go to this college and I'm going to be a CEO by 29, you know, all that stuff, right? But I think the key thing, especially like if we want to like specifically target energy and business and growing that side of
告诉他们以某种特定方式对待你，也就是像对待一个自信的人那样，他们就会那样做。他们唯一能参考的就是你选择展现出来的那个版本的自己。对，有一句名言。为了，为了，为了获得成功，你必须在任何时候都呈现出一种成功的形象，对吧？我听过这样一个商业理论。因为，你知道的，我认为我们在二十几岁时会感到非常害怕，因为我们好像，我们根本不知道自己在干什么。而且我们被灌输了各种压力，必须表现得像：“哦，我在大学里要门门拿A，我要去这所名牌大学，我还要在29岁之前当上CEO”，你知道的，所有这些东西，对吧？但我觉得最关键的一点，尤其是如果我们想专门针对能量、商业以及拓展那方面的
yourself um be prepared and i think that's it in everything like i don't drink any time i'm before like i will never drink before i'm filming the next day because i know that my energy will be impacted by a hangover so the things that you really want in life if you're given the opportunity you have to make sure that you're ready so that confidence of course is a muscle that you you build, but also there's micro habits that you can make that directly impact your confidence. You're not going to be confident if you're 15 minutes late for the meeting. You literally have a hangover from hell. You're, you don't know, you didn't even read what this conversation is about. So fake it until you make it be prepared to fake it. You know what I mean? Like have the preparation done.
你自己，做好准备，我认为这适用于任何事。比如我不喝酒，在任何时候，比如我绝不会在第二天拍摄前喝酒，因为我知道宿醉会影响我的状态。所以你真正想要的生活中的东西，如果机会降临，你必须确保自己已经准备好了。所以自信当然是一块需要你去锻炼的肌肉，但同时也有一些微习惯你可以养成，它们会直接影响你的自信。如果你开会迟到15分钟，你是不可能自信的。你正顶着要命的宿醉。你甚至不知道，你甚至都没读过这次谈话的内容是什么。所以，“假装直到你成功”意味着你要做好“假装”的准备。你知道我的意思吗？就是把准备工作做好。
And I think that's also really important when it comes to like your personal life too, where it's like, if you're going into a date, it's very easy just to like be just scared of the situation. You know what I mean? And just like fall back into old habits. But like, again, what you're saying about that energy, like I love how you visualize that. And I think it's so real. And the biggest thing that I've noticed in my life, now that I've started to respect myself,
而且我认为当涉及到你的个人生活时，这一点也同样重要，比如，如果你要去约会，很容易就会对这种情况感到害怕。你知道我的意思吗？然后只是退回到老旧的习惯中。但是，就像你刚才谈到的那种能量，我太喜欢你的可视化方法了。我觉得这太真实了。我在生活中注意到的最大的一件事是，现在我开始尊重自己了，
people respect me. So when I was like either getting. like sloppy drunk on a first day or like kind of being all over the place in my work, you know, all this stuff. Find out what giving yourself respect looks like. I can't tell you what that is. Only you can know what that is. But I know that all of us intuitively know what respect looks like to ourselves.
人们也开始尊重我。所以当我以前在第一次约会上烂醉如泥，或者在工作中丢三落四的时候，你知道的，所有这些。去弄清楚“给予自己尊重”到底是什么样的。我没法告诉你那是什么。只有你自己知道。但我知道我们所有人都凭直觉知道什么才是对自己的尊重。
Like and I think while I give this advice also know that is such a fluid journey and do not be overly rigid. Like you could be a CEO in the morning, kill a meeting, go on. a date go get drunk and order like Taco Bell the next day like it's okay but like also know like your higher goals so know that growth my growth has been very fucking messy and I still don't have all the answers but I think you can't you don't lose if you don't quit and like I have a lot of journeys that I'm still working with with my confidence and with who I want to be but I just know that like I'd rather chase the dream than chase the wrong things that I know don't serve me anymore.
而且我认为在听取这些建议的同时，也要明白这是一个非常多变的过程，不要过于死板。比如你可能早上是个CEO，完美拿下了一场会议，去约会，然后第二天去喝得酩酊大醉并点一顿塔可钟外卖，这都没关系，但也要清楚你更高的目标。所以要明白，我的成长过程一直都一团糟，我到现在也并不是掌握了所有答案，但我认为只要你不放弃，你就不会输。而且我知道，在培养自信以及塑造我想成为的样子的道路上，我还有很多功课要做，但我只知道，比起追逐那些我知道不再适合我的错误事物，我宁愿去追逐梦想。
2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong.
2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析心理坚韧度、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康与健身专家等对话，带大家看穿主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾以为种子油天生具有炎性反应。我们搞错了。
Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-P-Cent on the I-Hart Radio. app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking.
我们在世界上大惊小怪的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。节目名称是 T-W-O-P-Cent，可在 IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上拍打小姬姆的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不关心黑人时。我知道你在想什么。
What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at It podcast. I'm Sam Jette. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all. all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack.
乔治·布什跟小姬姆到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每集节目中，我们会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过那段日子的。包括最近一集请到了马克·拉蒙特·希尔，畅所欲言。大谈80年代的可卡因。把话说清楚，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为可卡因。
I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah.
我随时都可以聊当年的可卡因，只是想让大家知道。我的意思是，马克，这已经是我们第二集讨论可卡因了。所以我开始看出这里有一条贯穿始终的线索。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在桌面上。谢谢你补充完这句话。我不认为还有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要。真的吗？是的。
For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we, are in possession of the thing.
对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将把我在心理健康领域十多年的经验以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话带给大家。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们对某样东西进行追逐时，我们会太过于投入到这场追逐中，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了这样东西。
And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're afraid?
而我们却还在继续追逐。并且我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们总是在盯着记分牌。生活成了关于赢输的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要，还是你做一个好人只是因为你害怕？
Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure and purpose on my new podcast,
因为兄弟，这是两种截然不同的动机。绝对是的。这是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能够真正地做一个好人。和我——基尔·盖恩斯一起，在我的新播客中，进行关于疗愈、成长、父职、压力和目标的真实对话。
Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story.
《Learn the Hard Way》。打开你免费的 iHeartRadio App。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻之中。随后的家事法庭听证会暴露出她故事中明显的前后矛盾之处。
This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Sond's, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of Internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected.
这引发了一场长达数年的法庭之战来证明真相。森兹女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案件。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税都被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。
They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Lesbian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·莱斯比安和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的大脑都要炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了后果。
Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as, Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped Podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I think the things that we've talked about are really valuable for not just people like you know, like just people in their 20s, right? Especially like women in their 20s because this is, everyone wants to be confident. Everyone wants to have like these amazing relationships and whatnot. But it's a lot harder to do it and like having a bit of a sense of like how you can go about that just by by controlling something that is very much completely in your control.
女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被以欺诈罪起诉。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这件事不会结束。在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《Love Trapped Podcast》。我认为我们讨论的事情不仅对像你这样的人很有价值，你知道的，比如二十几岁的人，对吧？特别是二十几岁的女性，因为这正是，每个人都想变得自信。每个人都想拥有像这样美好的关系之类的事情。但要做到这一点要难得多，而且掌握一些方法，仅仅通过控制那些完全在你掌控之中的事情来达成目标，
Like your confidence levels is like super super valuable. So I want to say thank you so much for coming on this show. Thank you so much for finding time to chat. It was honestly inlining for me. I feel inspired. I feel like I'm going to go out and buy this like outfit that I really wanted to buy. I got. Send me a tag.
比如你的自信水平，这真的是超级超级有价值。所以我想对你说，非常感谢你来到这个节目。非常感谢你抽出时间来聊天。老实说，这对我有很大的启发。我感到很受鼓舞。我觉得我要出门去买这套我一直想买的衣服了。买起来。发给我看。
I'm going to. I'm going to. I'm going to. I'll wear it when I see you. I'll wear it out for dinner with you. We can look like hot. So thank you so much. Thank you for having me, Gemma. You're a bright light to the world and you're helping all of us navigate our 20s. So I'm so grateful for you and thank you for having me. God, look at this positivity circle here. Also, if you are not following tip, what are you doing? What are you doing? Come on. She's so funny. She is just like hilarious. confident magnetic. She posts so many like good little nuggets of information and also just like really like high quality content. You obviously do street hearts at NYC, which is like your matchmaking show. You post tips for people who want to muddle. You just post like New York tips. Anything that you need, she's a big sister. She's your New York big sister. She's your confidence big sister. So go and give her a follow. And as always, if you enjoy the podcast, please feel free to give a five-star review. Wherever you are listening right now,
我会的。我会的。我会的。我见你的时候会穿它的。我会穿着它和你一起出去吃晚餐。我们可以看起来火辣性感。非常谢谢你。谢谢你邀请我，杰玛。你是照亮世界的一束光，你正在帮助我们所有人度过二十几岁的青春期。所以我非常感激你，谢谢你邀请我。天哪，看看这里的正能量磁场。另外，如果你还没有关注蒂普，你在干什么呢？你在干什么呢？拜托。她太搞笑了。她简直太搞笑、自信、充满磁性。她发布了那么多优质的小干货，而且内容质量真的非常高。你显然在纽约做街头心跳节目，也就是你的红娘节目。你为想要建模的人发布小贴士。你只发布纽约的小贴士。任何你需要的东西，她就像你的大姐姐。她就是你的纽约大姐姐。她就是你的自信大姐姐。所以快去关注她吧。一如既往，如果你喜欢这个播客，请随时留下五星好评。无论你现在在哪里收听，
make sure that you're following so that you know when new episodes are coming out. If you have an episode suggestion, please follow us at That Psychology Podcast or just follow us because you want to because we share behind the scenes, video content, anything, everything over on that platform. So it was so great to have you here.
请确保你点击了关注，这样你就不会错过新节目的更新。如果你有节目建议，请在 That Psychology Podcast 关注我们，或者仅仅因为你想关注而关注，因为我们在那个平台上分享幕后花絮、视频内容，各种各样的一切。很高兴你能来到这里。
And as always, we will be back next week with another episode. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
一如既往，我们下周将带着另一集节目回归。《2%》。这就是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析心理坚韧度、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。
That's TWO.% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends.
节目名称是 TWO.%，可在 IHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。当一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他绝不能就这样逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女性朋友们。听闺蜜的话。
Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it, Pop. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
相信我，宝贝，在 iheart radio app、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。在《Look Back at It》中。从1979年开始，那对对我来说是一个巨大的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·杰伊。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每集节目中，我们会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过那段日子的。
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. I mean, it was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games.
与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是一个疯狂的年份。我的意思是，那是一个疯狂的年份。我不认为还有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要。在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师和主持人基尔·盖恩斯。
This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHeart podcast Guaranteed Human There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这个空间探讨的是黑人男性的经历，进行坦诚的对话，而这些对话在其他任何地方其实都不太安全，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人身披盔甲。它向世界传递的信号是，你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要去使用它。在 AHA Radio App、Apple Podcast 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《Learn the Hard Way》。这是一档 iHeart 播客，由真人呈现。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。